his legs are hopefully with your ticket
as usual we've been discussing Android
development topics prioritized from the
moderator so please get your questions
into the moderator each week as early as
you can so we get a chance to look at
them I'm rich timer and I'm joined here
in London by Chris minds yeah and on the
Hangout we've already got your see hey
guys and now hey guys are you in the
office as well background yeah
it's similar like POC yeah that was my
avatar you know just as well Wow people
from the co-creation hub in Nigeria hey
that can see you guys thanks ok I got a
question and if I've got multiple apks
and I have a service in one that I want
to make use of any others
is it better to explore the service in
the manifest or should I just use a IDL
and embed the a IDL filing the other
apks this is multiple separate
applications on the same device as
opposed in the developer console depends
how much control you run at the service
really if you want to start calling
methods on the service you ask you that
hey I do it which might start and stop
it no no Ernie so were the same
certificate I guess no they're gonna be
so I'm at different certificates this is
a thing character yes they or dlz or any
bet and you're always gonna guarantee
that the first app is on there when the
second up is running yeah the first apps
gonna be on though and the second ones
are running
it's whether to use a ID LT is the
method calls through or just try and
have set
in ten services yeah handle individual
calls yeah you can guarantee the first
ones on there and then maybe there's
many multiple other ones I would go at
the area at the ailment up till thanks
any others from the hangout flop Before
we jump into the moderator no welcome to
the other six people that just joined us
I think to zoom in on the chat window
again because we always do this and I
can't read yeah nothing in there for now
sure yang clans Steven Jamie well okay
so Mike has asked about theming and to
me about flaming edge effect so that's
the glow you get when you over scroll a
ListView or any sort of scrolling
container means a stir why can't you
start basically walking change of color
or anything like that and the main
reason for that really is that edge
effect is supposed to be consistent
across all apps so you're not release
it's for the user to then throw
different colors and different styles
that you can easily change it comes a
bit jarring so that's the real reason
really just keep consistency and you can
change it but you'd have to sort of
import the contain yourself and change
or the edge effect and the troubles we
have another question from Ram um he's
asking when a service gets restarted
will it reset the timer under the app
settings for its service um I think it
will but I cannot guarantee maybe you'll
just try it out some of you guys know
about his behavior I don't know okay
hey Tommy my key difference anyway
because it's fine this and maybe he
wants if the user goes in there sorry
user can see it but regarding your the
second part a few questions what will
happen to static objects reference
reference inside the service class any
object any static object that lives on
the heap will be there until you're
processed terminate
so of course the static objects will be
there I also wrote an announcement but
you have to be very very careful if one
of your aesthetic objects keeps a
reference on a service or any other
object that keeps the reference on a
service you will actually leak that
service minutes restarted so you have to
be very careful there because it's some
sometimes it's easy to create a memory
leak if you're using a static object so
you can do it but be very careful okay I
can ask a question yeah I played with
the billing service of version 3 and
they want to check to get the squ
details from the Google Play and it not
it not give me it's a the list was that
I received was blank with no items is it
work or maybe I was doing something
wrong recently updated the list on the
console I have dated the list but the
checks that I was doing it was two or
three hovers after it the list was empty
that's interesting
yes I did everything that you have
writen in the developers Android close
to the wire it can take more than two or
three hours for these changes to go
through the same as when you publish an
application I've seen updates to
descriptions and graphics and in-app
billing take longer than three hours
before ok but if I call it it works it's
no I don't have any problem with sound
surprised I need to I I will get the
list of the items I have publish it in
the Google Play ok I will try another
time yeah because we thought you Fredo
gets cached
in the market play it so that the mark
that as well and then like a cash fresh
hold and we're like no he hasn't been
refreshed before I was it sort of
elevate yourself
that's it guess billing issues like this
do full damage to not waiting wrong
enough but what should we don't have a
exact precise time for how long it takes
for the in-app billing items to fill
through to your nearest cache server
foreplay but yeah it's only Kentucky few
hours and they can maybe make an example
in the code that you said and maybe for
a checking the items for that anyway
because there's examples that going with
the code and is only for buy buy items
and not for chicken to checking
okay yeah I thought we did have sample
code for that in me we have a full
sample application that goes along with
it as opposed to just the sample code on
the on the in-app billing site and make
the application should have all the
sample code inside it there's also a
demo excuse that you can check so you
can change your Merchant ID and you'll
get all the demo ones so that's that's
how you test if it works and then
obviously even then shift over to your
specific SKUs and test your actual items
so yeah
it's why it's a person okay thanks have
you found the test application
have you found the sample in-app billing
application yeah I check it it's working
fine but there is no simple for getting
list from just from the Google Play you
can only buy items or a child or check
supplier subscription and not getting
saliste been updated to include getting
the list and finding prices or the free
check it okay thanks I've just done a
quick look into the source code for the
running time for a service and it's
based on the amount of time since that
process was start
so if the service is restarted but the
process that service is in isn't
restarted and the time under the app
settings won't be reset okay okay what's
up next
yeah anyone yeah we had a question
regarding some might be an important one
um regarding cursors yeah from Montano
in Brazil um he asked us okay how can I
don't commit occurs a leak I'm using
content provider and as in query handled
to do a simple query but occurs oblique
happens should I close the cursor
manually in general you should always
close your Curless you should be really
careful about not leaking cursors there
was epic nanano de api is there it would
call activity start managing cursor and
submerged cursor and then the activity
or Android would take over and manage to
cross over you corresponding to the to
the lifecycle but to be honest you
should you don't reduce any of these
classes anymore you should rely on
loader manager and cursor loader so take
a look at them
and they should help you out and they
also take care of all the life cycle
stuff and configuration changes and all
the kinds of things so you should
generally use loader management and
others I've got a question which cancer
are in surgery as ask question about
widget and cell sizes so he said that on
ICS and jelly bean the cell size is 70
you calculate it a certain way yeah and
then on a tablet you sell out same size
but it's any free sales to the fall how
do you they didn't sell size on
different devices the cell size is the
same on all devices in dibs dibs
other than the fact we put padding on
in ice cream sandwiches above where
where's the question it's the second
page second page it's the JRE
the formula for JD sir no sir
why is that 7th 250 with knees bent
three cells instead of four I wasn't
aware that it did I'm pretty sure on
what device mr. JRE if you're if you're
watching what device he is seeing that a
four cell 250 dip with widget is only
spending three cells and not four are
you sure it is free whip and goes to
free cells but the cells are smaller
because the bad maybe this cells a
smaller no maybe it's a custom one
custom launcher yeah
it should definitely be spending for
cells there 250 tips of width so it's a
bit of strange but if you have any more
details on it then please put them
through about the devices using and I'll
test it over here as well but I've not
seen that behavior before and so Jane
Elia has asked face recognition and he
has saw the opencv which is a popular 90
library there's been including the
Android source tree for a while he's
asking is there any way we can access
that via the NDK not that I'm aware of
you can you can see be quite easily your
own application there are some Java
bindings which I've released yeah it's
better to use it yeah but the intro of
using the Java bond is that you're
constantly doing genie calls so it's
gonna performs an impact so you're
better off doing all the OpenCV calls in
negative and then only calling through
what you need to gin it but yeah I don't
know an easy way where you can easily
use the supplied over
see the lip see ya I don't Reno nope
nope okay that's one how about embedding
it in the application using J and I to
call throw some recompile and put it in
an application yes what I said so they
ate supplier loaded sort of gay and I
bindings which is quite nice and we
focus a bit I've used it for the other
thing back on the widget sizing of
course is the Android design in action
last Friday or Thursday or Monday
whenever they published hit was
designing widgets as well so if you are
looking at designing widgets for Android
applications it's a great place to go
and check out on the Android developers
YouTube channel look for Android design
in action and will see all of their
shows there and last week was all about
designing widgets and it did have a
section on the sizing and the padding
you have to put on gingerbread ones ice
cream sandwich also we have a the AOSP
ADT template widget
maybe life an hour if not it's going
live very soon so be able to uh from
inside a project just right-click for
our new Android object and choose widget
and then it says if you like you can
choose what size that is configurable
whether it's resizable well that sort of
stuff we got our plan the widget status
he has Nexus 7 model zoom Galaxy Nexus
with default launchers all the same
issue I just checked widgets on here and
they are coming up for selves when they
say they're for sells so it's the 250 DP
what's being specified as the minimum
width or is he just specifying that as a
maximum weight doesn't say
my children both cases inflate four
cells and not three yeah we all the ones
on I'm running a nexus 10 here strange
what's next well keep looking me that at
the same time Marius is asked do we
recommend what what do you recommend for
usin a list of you having rows with
multiple widgets so you've got to sort
of to test views at button etc etc do
you read zero do recommend a cursor
adapter or a base adapter with a
ArrayList or of a connection as data
source as you got a database behind it
so yeah it totally depends on what your
data source is previously if it's on the
database it's probably easy to use a
cursor adapter with a cursor loader and
then you'll get all the freeness or the
goodness from having it automatically
update itself if you've got objects then
caring a basis adapter is probably the
way to go it depends on the data source
really model objects you've got yeah if
you want to do yes them caching stick
based adapter in encoding that yeah
that's what objects doing if you're
doing lots lots of bitmaps is new idea
to and he's taught the references to
those bitmaps and not and as they go up
the top and you get them passed back in
again load the new images into the
current bitmaps instead of recycling the
old ones and loading new ones you don't
you keep to get fragmented yeah but
yours were three careful
we'll use a hello cash or something and
I think the payments it depends on your
data source or any other questions
through the more than 16 minutes waiting
minutes
any questions in a hangout no no your
the quality is much better today than
the previous time we can hear what you
and you're saying today okay well
Carolyn I'll check the G+ thread yeah
and then I won't check the YouTube
comments because it's useless there are
only Commons on it or on a deep LeBron
II we're being cruel doing a hangout
whilst some people are suffering over
500 server errors and timer
sorry about that Rob consistency is more
important to us well we just didn't want
to shift it by half an hour so you could
all just come on and complain to us
that's the real reason and kitesurfer
has asked what is that what are the do's
and don'ts when implementing a custom
group sort of like your pager
it's a complex sort of issue to do this
con stuff there's no sort of do's and
don'ts to it have a look at you page a
it's very very readable it's a very good
example of how to do a custom sort of it
view group and within adapt with an
adapter base so I would learn from Preet
and from the framework classes rather
than trying to read books well and
because they are very readable almost
fun Michael Becker's chimed in saying
that actually if he uses 250 dps for min
heightened min width he's getting three
problems on an SW six and a few device
these let you put up six to eighty to
get for crimes if multiple people say
it's definitely worth checking out mmm
yeah where for most of you know I was on
the impression that the cell sizes
change based on device you have
different cell sizes if you in portrait
and if you're in landscape here that's
the minimum should always be the same
definitely been with yeah should be
number of cells we shall investigate and
get back to you for stat in Germany has
asked about the geocoding API
specifically get location I get from
location and he seems to be seeing that
again it's mean to me some issues with
not getting results back or 500 issues
yeah there's not much to say really did
the server from that server I seem to
remember living in it it's mean there's
docs about you won't always get replies
and yeah we've had a few cases of this
before and the recommendation is often
beaten to use the Android geo code or
API and then if you don't get a response
or you get an unsatisfactory response
use the Web API as a backup mechanism
there's definitely some cases I can't
remember the exact cases are but you'll
just fall back on the web it's come all
the others no this is reverse lookup
addresses and things oh yeah it was
either what there's some easy Wi-Fi uh
yes sorry recovery answer that and no
but there is the Web API which is more
reliable and I'm apps
anything else if you're inside the
Hangout prosper seeing what new has
appeared we've got 19 questions now we
started the especially with nine
questions and ten more of a pitcher in
the session chatter it's a yo-yo people
yeah if Jessica's asking if there's any
way of customizing the included Google
Apps Google Talk Google Play Store with
customized look to feel more like
commercial places know which not of
course Google Talk we have a full API
through Google Talk you Yammer based or
whatever it is it yeah yeah
so you can you can write your home
Google Talk line if you want there are
several out there and make it look nice
themed based or doesn't have an API so
you have to use the the Google branded
Play Store but for all these kind of
questions where sir yes who to contact
to talk about support it is if you go to
source.android.com forward slash
compatibility there's a link at the
bottom of the page for joining the
ecosystem and all of these things fall
under manufacturers that have passed the
compatibility test suite and become part
of ecosystem and then can talk to their
partner manager which is does every I've
gotta read it you got if you know we
have a question right here I have two
single tasks activities ie nbb is
started from a and I want to and one
from B to kill the app system that exit
and process that Co process we were
starting closing B and restarting is
their way to kill the whole app I think
we say this multiple times before it's
very very bad practice to kill your app
because the runtime is actually managing
your app and when it's it's your AB is
only killed in the case that there are
no resources and we have to kill the
process so
you have to have a very good reason to
call the functions ug you just mentioned
here so in general you should find a way
through it and and really not not to
kill your process or exiting your app
one of the ways of doing it is if both a
and B register a broadcast listener and
then you broadcast an intent when you
want to shut down and just call finish
in each activity that way you're not
killing the we are having after what I
said before we are having a little
trouble hearing its mischenko is a
question or write it as a comment yeah
you just put the gist of the message
comment first and we'll read unless
everyone else can scroll down you were
looking into something and you're
writing an application I may because
I've taken using table oriented
architecture for data centric Android
apps I know what table are you sure you
should always provide the best user
experience perfrom factor so if you--if
you have a data centric AB and
and showing some content you should
always make sure it runs across all the
devices from your smartphone to the
tablet and use different layouts for
that and think about what what is the
best way I could present my content to
the user so what was this your question
or so title centralizes how'd you go
about writing datacenter cams scenarios
if you look at like stock exchange like
information is stale as soon as you've
got it almost so again it's a case if
you've got to think of what's the best
way of transferring the data what time
can you store it does it have a need
updating what pointers that come use
useless kind of to the user it does
depend on the use case and there's a lot
of variation in that it might be is the
data in your application static data or
is it very dynamic so you'll be
frequently updating the data storing it
on the device and showing it to the user
yes and there's a lot of data I take it
I think Matt is right you have to come
up with a strategy and how you cache
data when how you're fetching data and
all these kind of things so what you can
do in your case may be if you have a
visit or something you can think about a
strategy using some exponential back-off
algorithm and pull the data mmm yeah I
think you
I don't know how often you have you to
refresh your data but you can use a
service and a background and pull data
from time to time but in general you
have to look at your requirements and
then then from there
judge on your strategy for carrying when
you're loading data when you're doing
prefetching and all this kind of thing
it's important because it also affects
battery life so you also have one minute
before we finish today mr. Terrence Eden
has joined the chat hey that's her it's
good to see you no microphone table
today oh well never mind I did I'm
investigating using bluetooth so I've
got an ODB port in my car so I can plug
a Bluetooth thing into that I can
communicate with Android what I can't do
is use a VoIP which allows me to update
the head end of my phone and I've seen
some devices by some Samsung's and some
HTC's Bluetooth stack which do have that
I just wondered if there's any official
way in stock Android doing anything
useful with Bluetooth yes so we have if
you go to the Bluetooth page in the API
Docs it shows you which profiles are
officially supported in which versions
of Android we have a doc which lists
those so a to the audio profile 2 DP is
supported but you're only guaranteed to
have that lowest quality audio
supportive yeah we're gonna code is
called foots CBC yeah you can ask the
device if there are if there are better
codecs on there and most of them will
have but in terms of video there's no
default support in Android for assume
I'm sorry not the video the ABR CP
allows you to send messages like the
track that you're playing so I mean
we've been automatically since 2009 on
the Google bug thing haven't had any
response my six-year-old blackberry can
do it so I'm just wondering if there's
any way to get that into Android if you
always try to use the Blues library
directly
in native coat least be compiled another
module I thought it must be in there
because we were using have you have you
tried air so they you know it from
native code the program is it let's not
support it they lose in if you look in
the source code for Android it says
using the Blues API version 1.0 for now
and that was a couple of years ago so
the native blues doesn't have it which
is why I'm wondering if there's any way
to get directly to the blue tees if
Google can't support that's all
five-year-olds standard what what else
can we do make a contribution to the
Android Open Source project bingo so it
is in CyanogenMod so it has been
submitted to a OSP about knowing that
it's not necesarily right do is be
signage embodies a separate fork off of
a OSP so that may not have been a
contribution given to the AOSP guys i
will check and see if I can push it on
them hmm yeah you just have to wait and
see I guess what the next version of
Android holds the Bluetooth but we hear
we can't pre-announce anything I'll talk
about future pieces
somebody has picked up your six-year-old
issue from the day that Android started
you hanging off this one and thanks for
joining us and asking your final
question of the day Terrence at least
your your the profile of the issue has
been raised even higher
thanks everyone else to joining us in
the Hangout today we'll be back at the
same time Oh will we be back at the same
time next week that's a good question no
the teams traveling next week two
o'clock is a very awkward time in
America we'll make an announcement
sometime soon about whether it will be
at the same time next week just guys
thanks guys bye my